it is the last taboo
it is the one thing nobody
relishes talking about
why did you write a book about people's
right to die
understand please that
first came the documentary
and then we were a year into
the documentary which i both narrate
and i am the interviewer when
i decided to write the book
based on the documentary so
just to be clear the documentary came
first the book is
representing 25
or so of the 50
interviews that i did during the
film process around the country
and i think chris it goes way back
my mother died at 49
i was 19. she had liver cancer
she was in terrible pain
and big to die and
nobody listened and she
suffered my father
died 11 months later
i have a broken heart
when my husband
of 54 years my late husband
john rheem and i were married
his father and mother were both alive
and then at age 72
his father who was living alone
on a farm in pennsylvania
after having had a career in journalism
had diabetic retinopathy
he could no longer see
and he took his own life
and then at age 92
my mother-in-law who had
terrible back pains terrible
headaches about which
nothing could be done
that she was willing to do for example
surgery she took her own life
so the idea of
making a decision about
your own life and when
it should end has really been
in my mind for a very long time
this is a very uncomfortable topic for
most people to discuss isn't it
most people would rather not talk about
death i can remember speaking
at a church in upstate new york and
there were about 350 people in the
congregation
and i started out by saying
how many of you are planning not
to die and of course there was this
little
titter within the congregation a nervous
titter people really don't want
to talk about death it is
the last taboo they would rather
pretend it's never going to happen
as children do but we
as adults must reach a point
where we are not only willing to talk
about it
we need to plan for it so
that we if we choose
not to don't end up in a hospital
attached to all kinds of tubes and
oxygen and seeing
hearing nothing
just dying who wants to do that
not i i want to be in my
own bed i want to be in my
own home with my husband
my children my grandchildren with me
and i want to be able to say goodbye
and tell them how much i love them
so i am planning ahead
and truly chris the purpose of
both the documentary and the book
are to get people to
talk about what it is
they want at the end of life
what is stopping people from having that
kind of a death
at home with the family around them why
aren't people having that kind of a
death at the moment
too many laws in place
there are nine states within the united
states plus
the district of columbia where i live
which do allow medical
aid in dying which is
the focus of the film the focus of
my book those nine states and dc
allow one to reach out to
a doctor who will
determine truthfully whether that
individual is within six months
of death that has to
then be confirmed by a second
doctor and in some cases
there has to be a psychiatric
examination where
no one other than the patient
him or herself can be there
to ensure that there is no
pressure coming from anyone
in the family or friends
that that individual truly
is ready to die having reached that
point
in an illness where
life is no longer tolerable
so once that happens
then individuals are given
the medication which they must
self-administer
in one way or another
and that is
what i intend to do
when my time comes
what if you're not in one of those nine
states
you're in trouble because
if you do not have the wherewithal
of establishing residents in one of
those states
as a woman about whom you may have read
brittany menard who was
a 29 year old woman
who had just married she
and her husband
moved from california which
did not have medical aid in dying
at the time to oregon
which did because it was
found she had a massive
brain tumor and was going to be
dead within six months
and she wanted to take charge
of her own dying process
she was having horrendous headaches
plus seizures she
was at times simply not
able to move to do anything
for herself so she and her
husband had to pull up stakes
moved to oregon establish residents
find doctors who were
willing to help her and
in the end on november
the first a date she had chosen
she wasn't sure whether she was going to
carry through it
on that date but she woke up
had two massive seizures
and said to her husband dan diaz
today is the day her mother
her stepfather her dearest friends
her husband were all with her
she took the medication and she died
peacefully
and that is what so many people
cannot afford to do how many
people had the wherewithal
to pick up and move from one state to
another
establish a new residence think of
the expense involved in fact dan
kept going back and forth to california
trying to hold on to his job
while they were in this process so
you know you have to make your
choices and brittany became
a world renowned figure
for having made the choice she did
you in europe with the exception
i gather of britain do not
have medical aid in dying
i don't know i'll be interested if
anybody in the comments can elaborate on
that do you know much about the european
stance on this
i do and i know that there
are a number of countries the
netherlands
um belgium
um
several others switzerland i think is
one of them as well
switzerland also have
medical aid in dying but they go even
further to euthanasia
that is the active
participant of the physician
who administers the
final dose of medication
is that the difference then the
difference between euthanasia and
assisted dying
is whether it's committed by the patient
or by the physician
precisely precisely and
in the united states it is
illegal to have the
physician administer that final dose
now having said that chris for years
under the table as it were
many doctors have been given
giving to their patients
their patients who may be close to death
that extra dose of morphine
that they know will take them over the
edge
but they don't acknowledge that what we
have here in this country one
in five people are eligible
because of the state in which they live
for medical aid and dying
now oregon is trying to make
some changes to their laws
in the case for example of someone
who may have als
or lou gehrig's disease who
has no muscular
strength whatsoever
and through
a technicality
which allows that person
to lift an elbow
and have that descend
to begin because
people with als cannot swallow
they begin a rectal
infusion of the medication
so it is
a very difficult topic
about which to speak but
i hope that speaking with you
and having your listeners hear
the importance of talking with your
family talking with your doctor
talking with your children about
what it is you want
at the end of life is so
extraordinarily important and mind you
i believe that if you want
god to be the only
decider i support you
100 if
on the other hand you want everything
medical science can provide
i support you 100
and i ask that you
support me
as i make my own decision
for what i want at the end of
life it definitely seems like
there are some really particular
quirks and odd ethical dilemmas that
we're coming up against here
for instance somebody with als being
able to move their elbow
and push down on a plunger thing like
what what really is changing here what
is the difference between the physician
doing it and the patient doing it
is it a moral and ethical question is it
a question of professional care
is it something to do with who is left
culpable
it it also seems totally crazy
that someone can try to
take their own life if they're
able-bodied
but can't be assisted in taking their
own life through the state
and that where's the difference between
murder and a physician like
one of the questions what what are the
justifications
for not allowing this to go forward what
does the other side of the aisle
to your stance say are the reasons for
this
not being allowed to happen there are
several and we talked
with a number of them both for
the film and in the book
first and foremost the roman
catholic church is the
largest opponent
to medical aid in dying
they argue that life is
sacred in whatever form
it exists and therefore
must not be ended in
any way other than through
god's will then
there are physicians
older ones for the most part
who continue to believe
that physicians should be in control
of what that
patient does or does not do
so there is a large portion of the
medical
profession in this country who do
not support medical aid and dying
they believe that their function
and their mission is to do everything
they can
to keep a patient alive
even sometimes when
keeping them alive does
more harm to that patient
than letting them go then
there is the disabled
community which is split
some argue that they
fear they will be
set apart
and somehow put to death
against their own will
and thereby they do not
support medical aid in dying
and then there are those who are
disabled who believe
they've been left out of the law because
of this notion of self-administration
which is what the oregon law is
trying to get around with
this elbow release
finally there
is the african american community
which is so mistrustful
of the medical community because
of incidents for example
like where african americans were
deliberately
infected with syphilis
as part of an experiment so
i spoke with a wonderful
african methodist episcopal
pastor who said to me diane
if you can show me
that this method would be carried out
fairly and honestly
and with trust
i would support you but right
now that trust on the part
of the african-american community
is simply not there so
that's where the oppositions
are coming from what do the lawyers
say about this
the lawyers are secondary
the lawyers really are secondary
for example i've already
communicated with my own lawyer
with my own doctor with my
children with my husband
my wishes
are topmost and remain that way
do you think that there's an ethical
difference between
stopping stopping from keeping someone
alive
and giving someone something which makes
them die
i think you talk about the difference of
pulling pulling the tube out
versus administering a drug
um there are many
people who decide as
my late husband did to stop
old treatment on medication
in fact he was suffering
from extreme parkinson's disease
he reached a point where
he could no longer stand on his own
he could no longer feed himself
he could no longer bathe himself or
toilet himself
he said i have lost
so much sense of dignity
and if i continue to live on
in this way i will lose
even more and i'm not willing
to do that and so
he took what is called
the be said method
voluntarily stopping
eating and drinking
it took him 10 long days
to die without water without
food without medication
it's not an easy way to go
but he was in a nursing home
in maryland and of course
maryland did not then and does not
even now have medical aid in dying
so he had no other recourse
now the question you ask about
stopping treatment
many people do that
and go peacefully
and that may be
the choice that those without
medical aid in dying opt for
but in some roman catholic
hospitals that's not allowed
so you got to be careful where you
end up truly
you talk about a story a lady
i think maybe has a heart attack and
then gets angry when she's brought back
to life
can you tell us that she had
all her documents so clearly
evident in her apartment
saying do not resuscitate under
any circumstances but
when her neighbor
found her unconscious
she called 911
when you call 911
they are legally obligated
to resuscitate you to attempt
or to resuscitate you
and that's what happened to her and she
was furious
when she woke up and she was still alive
i i don't know who's to blame there i
don't know whether it's
the fault of the neighbor whether you
need to kind of have like a laminated
card that's on a
on a lanyard around your neck at all
times or something like that
but if you call 911
you've made the first wrong step in a
series
of wrong steps which is
why chris around the united states
we now have the development of
what are called death cafes
where people come together
neighbors church members
people who don't even know each other
to talk about what they want
at the end of life but those
neighborhood groups
are so important because it
means that your next door neighbor
knows what you do or
don't want at the end of life
the fact of the matter is that
talking about death clears
your own mind
helps you focus on what it
is you want or don't want
and helps you to move forward
knowing that you've taken control
of your own life and how it may
end i mean
for those who have
no recourse
i mean just think how horrible
it is to find someone you love
dead of a gunshot wound to
the head or the stomach
or a wrist
slit or however one in desperation
carries that out now many people
say to me well what's the difference
between medical aid and dying and
suicide
if one wishes
to die
and makes that decision without being
sick
but simply doesn't want to live anymore
that's a choice that that person
makes to end his
or her life i spoke with
a 37 year old mother
who had breast cancer that had gone
throughout her body
she said diane if i had my
way i'd live until i was
90. but i don't
i know i'm going to die and i
don't want my 13 year old son
to see me suffer at the end
it's a terrible thing to watch someone
suffer
as they die and so
she was one of the first who
got herself lined up
on that list as having expressed her
desire for medical aid in
dying even before it became legal
so that her doctor would know
exactly what she intended
to do now as it turned out
she decided at the end even though
she had the medication right there with
her
not to use it and that's the irony here
one third of the people
who received the medication
to use for medical aid in dying
don't use it only
two-thirds of all the people
who've been given this who've been
cleared by their doctors
to use this ultimately do
don't ask me why i mean they
make that decision but what they
are saying is i feel
comfort i feel at peace
because i have this medication
that i know i can use
if the suffering
becomes more than i want to tolerate
i think you're right i think most of it
is to do with
the peace of mind the feeling of being
in control
and what people don't want is to feel
like their destiny is no longer theirs
to choose
i think one of the challenges that we
have when having this conversation
is that as someone who is
well and healthy if you haven't
meditated for quite a while on what it's
like to die
and if you haven't seen somebody as you
have
far too many times uh suffer at the end
you can't really envision a world in
which
you wouldn't want to live for longer
everybody just thinks i'm just going to
keep on going why would i want to die
sooner obviously life is good
and i think that realizing there can be
a level of discomfort that you can reach
in life
where death is preferable to life
realizing that straight away is
something which
i i don't really even know if i'm that
i'm an only child with two parents
um both of whom are still alive so for
me
i've never had to face any sort of death
up close like loss of pets and stuff
like that but that's it
so for me i don't know what that's like
but i can completely see
why that would be the case how you could
get yourself to a stage where
the person is suffering and and so
the people around them as well right
your family are suffering watching you
suffer and you're suffering watching
them suffer watching you suffer so
it it ends up being a a big spiral
given the fact that i mean is this a
conversation you should just
have at the first stroke or the first
heart attack like is that the is that
the note when you're supposed to go
we'll start talking about it now
that's too late that's too late
how old are you chris 32
and how old are your parents 60s
have you ever had this kind of
conversation with him never once
and why not
i don't know i mean when you get to see
your parents it's usually not the first
topic on the agenda it's how have you
been how's the dogs what's happening
with work
oh i've got this new thing going on it
doesn't tend to be
how you open up the conversation and um
i've had a couple of conversations with
with my mum with regards to the sort of
service that she wants
but in terms of end of life which
actually
in terms of her experiences and everyone
else's experience is far more important
like that the type of casket that you're
cremated in matters far less than
the way that you spend your last few
months
so what would it take
for you to go from
talking about what kind of
service she wants at the end
to what kind
of process she
would want at the end of her life
i don't know i a question i have for you
is
is it the job is it the job of the
person
to bring up the the son daughter or
is it the mother father is it their job
it's anybody's job anybody's job for
example
a parent might say
you know i'm getting
a little older i'm 60 now
i'm not going to live forever
so i've been thinking about this
whole issue of what
kind of ending i'd like
do i want to go to a hospital
and get on that turn wheel
of one medication or one treatment or
one radiation after another
should i come down with something as
lethal as cancer or
do i just want to live
out the best of my days
toward the end of my life with my family
in my home in comfort
or a child your own age
might say you know mom and dad
i talked to this woman
the other day all about
medical aed and dying that's not really
legal
here in the uk
but is in other parts of the world
including in parts of the u.s
and it got me wondering
about my own life and what
i might want at the end of my life
and i'm wondering whether you
my parents have thought about
what you'd like at the end
and mind you it's not
one discussion it's
many discussions because
the first reaction on the part of your
parents might be
why do you want to talk about anything
so
dreary or negative
or depressing as that
and the response might be
well because i know eventually
it's going to happen it's going to
happen to all others
and i really would like to know
what you would like
in your own and
life thinking and
if that conversation doesn't take off
in the first time you raise it
i promise you after you
lead the house they'll be
thinking about what you've said and what
you've asked
and maybe start thinking about it
themselves i used to
say to my mother
and i think it's because deep down
i knew she was sick from the time i was
five years old
i used to say to her
mama i want to die before you
i don't ever want to be without you
and you know in my
own mind i think i had
a feeling i was going to lose her
early but even until
she was in that hospital
crying and begging
to die she had never talked about it
she had never talked about
and that was sad to me
i suppose the discomfort
the inertia that people need to get over
here
is do i want to deal with
the pain and the awkwardness of having
this conversation
with somebody that i care about and i
don't know how it's going to necessarily
make them feel and it's going to remind
them of their mortality and
maybe they're going to think that i'm
trying to get rid of them maybe they
think i'm after the inheritance
um the choices between that discomfort
or the discomfort of
end-of-life complications of stuff not
happening of things not being
being done correctly i imagine
that the vast majority of people no
matter how compelling your argument is
here
our denial of death is so strong we we
don't think that it's going to happen
not to me not to them not to my mum not
to my dad we push it off and
we sweep it under the rug i imagine that
the vast majority of people
get a fairly rude awakening upon the
first phone call that mum's had a
x heart attack stroke whatever fallen
down the stairs seriously
dad's forgetting things and we've got
early onset parkinson's we've got
alzheimer's we've got dementia we've got
whatever it might be um
and i imagine that most people
would then begin to think about this
conversation like that's pulling the
starter pistol it's like oh okay right
now we're into
we're into end of life
consideration period that's that's when
we do it
but you're saying that a better approach
is to do that when everybody's fit and
healthy and death's not at the door
exactly right and
it sounds as though as
an only child you are a faithful son
who
may be willing to brave
that first rejection
of the topic but
know that at some point
you're going to be faced with it
as is every single person
who's listening to this program
and therefore
doesn't it make sense to want to know
and to hear what
it is your parents may not even have
thought about it themselves
they may have you know they're having a
good time
they're sick in their 60s they're
healthy they're enjoying life
they're enjoying their son they're
traveling they're doing whatever they
want to do
and that's what john rheem and i
were doing for so many years
for 54 years
but i first
realized i mean we had
both talked a lot
we had both talked a lot
about death because of what i've said to
you
earlier and we had each
told the other that we would help the
other die
peacefully um
[Music]
and yet when the time came i
could do nothing to help him
and as a matter of fact
because i am known in this country
because of the radio
program i hosted for
nearly 40 years
the doctor warned me
and said diane don't
do anything that would
help him end his life
earlier don't do anything
because you would really
be in trouble and so
at the end i could do nothing
but early on i had heard that
shuffle in his walk he was a strapping
six foot tall he had worked in
his father's rock quarry he had
big shoulders he was built like a
football player
and watching him
[Music]
disappear physically
to go from 175
pounds down to about 120 pounds
i mean
pretty painful painful pretty painful
to watch and had
there been that law in maryland
i know john would have used it because
when he
talked to the doctor about his
wishes he said to him i want you to help
me die
and the doctor said legally ethically
morally i can do nothing
here in this state of maryland and the
only thing
you can do for yourself
is to stop eating drinking and taking
medication
and that's how he took it into his
own hands
it's such a savage way to finish a life
like it's watching that happen enduring
it
both from the inside and the outside is
just
i you know that as uncomfortable as the
conversation may be for everybody that's
listening who's thinking
should i bring this up with mum and dad
i've got this sense that i might i
probably
might be a good idea but also it's going
to be really awkward
imagining that imagining watching
someone that you love go through a week
and a half
fasted water fasted with no medication
whilst going through a ton of pain
from their physiology and then that
getting worse over time
i mean it's about as stark of a contrast
to the good death that you described
earlier on which is
in your house in your bed surrounded by
your loved ones
um yeah it really does
it really does highlight why it's an
important discussion
to have if people want to find out a
little bit more
or if there was a website that they
wanted to show their parents to give
them a little bit more information where
would you tell them to go
the documentary is going to
be released on pbs worldwide
in mid-april and
of course you have my book
but there is also
an organization here in the united
states
called compassion and choices
which provides information on
even how to have
the conversation
they're all kinds of information
out there there's another organization
called death with dignity
that came out of the hemlock
organization founded
many many years ago which in fact
included a prescription
how to take one's own life
but that is
no longer available
because the medication prescribed
is now off the market
and so having that
conversation with your family
with your doctor with your
friends with your neighbors
is really important chris i'm fascinated
with why you personally
were interested in talking to me
i think that meditating on death
and thinking about what happens at the
end is
one of the best ways that we can remind
ourselves why life's worth living
it's something that the stoics did
memento mori
to meditate on death um and increasingly
i like to do things i like to have
conversations on this show which
push people into areas that are
uncomfortable because there's not very
many places that you go
now that cause you to be uncomfortable
the
way that tv shows and our
information consumption diet is curated
now
is precisely done to feed you things
that make you feel good that
they confirm your existing belief
structures in the architecture of
what your life is already built around
and
i have conversations on here with people
whose
views i don't agree with all the time
but i think that it's incredibly
important
for people in 2021 to have their minds
exposed to stuff like that and also
sitting through a conversation like this
for 50 minutes and
feeling that discomfort sitting with it
learning to sit with the discomfort of
things like this
i think is such a valuable
tool um
the same way as looking at the night sky
it makes you feel small and
insignificant
it makes you it reminds you that you
know your time on this planet is
incredibly limited
it's this brief window of consciousness
bookended by
two eternities of nothing and
really it's only upon working out that
this
is an inevitability as you said put your
hand up if you don't intend on dying
um realizing that this is an
inevitability reminds us that we need to
find joy today
not tomorrow not next week not when i've
got the new car the new job the new
house not when the pandemic's over
that joy has to be found today
and i think although
talking about death every day might be a
little bit much i've
i fear that we've probably overshot that
and we don't talk about it enough
and hopefully today with this
conversation will have opened some
people's eyes to this and
spurred on some conversations that will
make you know it could make
hundreds of people's lives thousands of
people's passings
more comfortable well chris
i can't tell you how much i appreciate
those sentiments because
it is the last taboo
it is the one thing
nobody relishes
talking about and most people
would rather not do it
and i commend you
a healthy 30 year old
for being willing to take on this
subject
and converse with me about it
maybe i've planted a seed in your mind
and you'll see where it goes
diane thank you link to when my time
comes will be in the show notes below if
anybody wants to go and check that out
i'll also find some of the other links
that you've put in
you mentioned earlier on and they will
be there as well diane thank you so much
for today
chris thank you so much
[Music]
you